if you go back and watch my fight while
Bruce buffers announced me I'm staring
at little cap you're like this this is
not happening
I'm your hungover house Roy Wood jr. Oh
breakfast sensor perfect time
[Music]
you're supposed to be ten years old I
met a family who I'm flopped down from
the TV and blood sport is on with
jean-claude Van Damme I've seen it 1,000
times I did not care my dad burst in the
door you know no moves my mile away just
check this out he puts in a VHS tape and
on the screen pops up the very first UFC
fight in 1993 its hoist Gracie first Ken
Shamrock so you got a Brazilian guy in
Aggie versus this giant probably on
steroids
hot dog skin looking character and that
was a straight-up human cockfight like
he might as well put on his favorite
porno scene like it it [ __ ] the whole
vibe up with a party like it's over my
grandma was like what and the devil
dropped her meatball my mom was like oh
my god and my brother and I we're
mesmerised not by the fight on the
screen but with my dad and he was so
passionate and he looked at these guys
like they were his heroes and a light
bulb went off I want my dad to look at
me the way he looks at these guys on the
screen is exactly what I'm gonna do it
was first time my life ever realized
that so I became obsessed with mixed
martial arts it's all I thought about I
practiced I'd mimicked the moves of my
brother in the living room non-stop and
I'd vision myself grabbing the mic from
Joe Rogan to have the belt around my
waist my dad same cage side I'm like dad
we did it
really time you [ __ ] up the filler you
look at us now though J all those times
in the living room I know it sucked but
what's up man we didn't fast for 20
years later I'm pursuing this exact
dream in the UFC of a handful of fights
under my belt and things are good I'm
ranked top 10 in the world I'm chillin
I'm at home my phone rings I don't
recognize the number
it's a Las Vegas area code yeah that's
interesting I answer the phone it's my
boss it's Dana White president the UFC
Brendon Dana White here I got a fight
for you MGM Grand December 6 number 2
guy in the world before I could even
answer he hangs up the phone I'm like
well like I thought man it's weird I'm
like like 10 or 11 he's like number 2
why would they give me this fight he's
better at everything than me he's bigger
he's faster stronger
[ __ ] you I'm gonna do so I went straight
to a training camp like never before six
days a week three times a day to our
practices each I'm obsessed with winning
this fight it's all I think about when
you guys think about training camp you
think rocky hitting the slabs of meat
run up the stairs all that cute [ __ ] no
that's all [ __ ] I would train so
hard I went mi from every but I did I
did no interviews
I couldn't even text my family and
friends at night my hands were shaking
so bad I trained couldn't act a week
before the fight I felt so much pressure
like never before
it was 1:00 in the morning I went to a
24-hour fitness to run these nerves off
mind you I didn't eat for the entire day
because I'm so nervous I get on the
treadmill
there's not many people there's kind of
the weird situation at 1:00 in the
morning
and I'm running next thing I know I'm on
my back and I wake up I can hear people
going hey big man get up
you're I broke get up I can hear but I
can't see them I went temporary blind
for 24 hours but I was ready
so I dialed it backgrounds ready it's
finally the night of the fight MGM Grand
Las Vegas I'm in my locker room and I'm
warming up I'm feeling good and this one
they don't they don't show on those
behind the scenes those 24/7 there's my
locker room the blue corner then my
opponents in the room next to me what
separates us about two inches of drywall
I can hear everything I hear everything
so I'm warming up and I hear I'll get my
coaching mic the [ __ ] is that they look
at each other yo that's your that's your
opponent in the myths man all right like
you could do that you do that and don't
even worry about it yeah we'll do it
after he's probably tired like yeah
whatever you think man we act like that
never happening to keep moving and now
the showrunner comes and you always goes
comes your room goes fine the whole time
to roll that's when you know it's your
turn to go man it's your turn to fight
take one look in the mirror like damn
you look ready get the sweet warm-up
outfit on I hit the crowd I wish you
guys could feel this 25,000 people MGM
Grand
my name is on the marquee you're talking
Floyd Mayweather Mike Tyson
Conor McGregor Evander Holyfield the
best of all time have all won their
biggest fights in this exact arena this
was my time so I hit the crowd they're
chanting my name oh my god it's just
like the movies I get into the Octagon I
take one lap around I've never done this
before my career ever I look into the
crowd I look in the stands and front row
I see my father like damn it's exactly
how I pictured this sup Pop's I look
more into the front row and I see Will
Smith
shout-out to Fresh Prince what's up man
next to him I see ice-t Mikey what's up
ice-t from long order SUV I got wish it
was ice cube but it's up to you next to
him I see you Leonardo DiCaprio son I'm
talking a list and he's with two
timepieces around his arm like this and
I'm starstruck I'm like oh my god are
you ki are DiCaprio Jack from Titanic
I've seen that one thousand times man
this is not [ __ ] Jack Taylor singing
this is nuts
and the next to him I see my
ex-girlfriend yeah like well well well
look what the cat dragged in huh
couldn't get enough of the big man huh
enjoy the show [ __ ] so now I'm back to
my corner I'm doing my thing and then if
you ever seen the UFC my opponents
walking out the lights go dim his
interest music starts to play the lights
are flickering I've been a bunch of
fights before I've heard a bunch of
walkout music but never like this man
I mean he's Hawaiian so start off just
this Hawaiian hate just what the [ __ ] is
going on right now this was some white
boy burned down the Dole pineapple
factory [ __ ] this is some hateful
Hawaiian [ __ ] I was like I was
intimidated already [ __ ] he gets into
the ring he takes a lap around like holy
[ __ ] geez big I'm just looking up and
down like tattoos are way better than
mine that beard his beards been able to
use beard oil [ __ ] pomade in my hair
he has no pomade look at me look at me
and he's just pacing back and forth like
a lion now just go on man the rough gets
in between us he points at him goes are
you ready yes points because are you
ready like yes at this moment he goes
let's get it on
and this is every move I've ever seen
this is where the hero says some
inspiring badass [ __ ] like some William
Wallace you know freedom like I'm
looking I'm searching for it man I'm
like 300 like tonight we dine in Hell
and just run out of I got nothing and I
blame it on Leonardo DiCaprio front cuz
all I can think about is the scene in
Titanic man this is embarrassing
tell me the Rose is on the back of the
ship she like hates her man she's
willing to dive in and commit suicide
and Jack hatchlings like you give me
your hand you don't want to do this you
go back and watch my fight while Bruce
buffers announced me I'm staring at
Leroy Capra like this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I don't want again get up come on man
wait your whole life for this moment
focus now focus on [ __ ] jack right now
and then it's just all freakin laser and
man just I see nothing
and I just sprint at his big ass I
remember after that my head bouncing off
doctor I'm doing in and out of
consciousness like this hell is going on
right now and the ref is standing over
me like this but you out the way broad
middle of a fight and I stand up and I'm
like man you know I found out I lost
Leonardo DiCaprio and his face is going
like this oh my god I lost and now this
is the worst part of any professional
sports I don't care what sport you've
ever played any pro athlete out there
nothing beats this moment when you lose
a fight of that magnitude and you have
to gather all that crap you walked into
the Octagon like a hobo and do the
concussion shuffle out of that
and that crowd that was like Brandon oh
they flip-flop real fast this is the
real walk of shame because I got to go
through that goddamn crowd and get to
that locker room I'm walking I'm a
little out of it man I'm not in good
shape I see this guy and here's a team
shop shirt on he just looks him he goes
him the [ __ ] man I got a babysitter for
this [ __ ]
I looked at my coach's eye pocket
anyone have any cash I don't want to do
I'm sorry bro I tried I keep going and
then just the boo birds right now I'm
getting popcorn thrown at me like oh my
god now the corn when I see this mom
were the two kids she had some big-ass
titties she's like this oh my god I
could use a hug my going for a hug and
her son who couldn't be more than 13
goes oh mom don't hug him he's a loser
[ __ ] you bro now the tears I'm about to
get emotional I'm like just makes it a
lot don't cry in front of a man just go
when I get into that locker room now
before any fight that locker room is
pumping man there's life there's music
people are dancing there's dreams
aspirations it's the best after that
place is dark it's a prison cell it is
cold all the winners are gone it's just
filled with the toughest guys in the
world with broken bones they're
concussed again half of their pay it's
the most depressing place you've ever
seen in your life
I've never been to lobby of abortion
clinic but I imagine
some dark [ __ ] I realized it so sad now
I'm making my way to my little cubby my
locker and I'm still out of it I will
never forget this there's this giant
Asian doctor and he goes mr. shop yo lip
and he points to this mirror I'm like
what's wrong with my lip
oh my god my [ __ ] was split like the Red
Sea you could just see gum bone I look
like [ __ ] Joaquin Phoenix
I was just he takes out the biggest
syringe you've ever seen and goes this
is going to hurt I have to chuckling you
think that's gonna hurt me
do you realize what I just went through
I just had a giant Hawaiian bashing my
brains on top of that I'm pretty sure
he's [ __ ] my ex-girlfriend on top of
that they stuck her in front row so she
could see this ass-whooping in person on
top of that all I can picture is my boss
Dana White jacking off to my demise as
onion beat up kill him kill him
so I looked at doctor and I said bring
it on doc that needle hit my lip he was
not lying there are no words in the
English language to describe that pain
maybe in Hebrew or some [ __ ] I don't
know 12 stitches in the front 14 in the
back [ __ ] is real and now I'm sitting at
my locker
I'm hunched over my heads in my hands
the adrenaline from the fight wears off
the numbing pain from my lip wears off
and it hits me for the first time in my
life ever you will never be world
champion this is it for you I wish I
could stay in front he guys and say I
shed won like North Korean terror on
[Laughter]
nah man my big ass was howling at the
heavens
I was howling crying my coach is like
we're not equipped to deal with this
they laugh way to go guys
and I'm so exhausted from crying
and there's snot and I find myself on
the ground in the fetal position I look
like a jumbo shrimp I'm just on the
ground snot bubbles tears I want to stay
there for the rest of my life people
leave they shut the lights out there's
like a janitor I'm still there crying
and in walks I see a corner my pair of
sandals walks in is my best friend and
partner in crime Brian the kid Callan he
walks up he stares that meeting goes the
old uppercut huh
he puts his hand out he picks me up I
look at me go I don't think this is for
me anymore man he looked earnest I don't
think it's for anybody
from that day on I've never stepped foot
in a ring again and I found my true
calling I'm on Comedy Central
I can't think Justin Eric everyone Ari
forgive me this chance I love you guys I
will never forget this thank you